la vie cette puce est importante pourquoi je suis dedans
Göteborg devant la loi
enfance, j'ai tout énoncé si
homme même si elle ne peut pas accoucher
ça fait mal et ça viendra dans un autre pays
aller de sorte que mabour a fait exactement cela
mon pays n'interdit pas du tout ces choses
lancé interdit par la loi et les chirurgiens
ou celui qui le fait pour la vie
la conclusion est avec une femme qui accouche
bébé regrette immédiatement les appartements là-bas
donner maintenant un autre testament supplémentaire
fond faire des appartements donner de l'argent tout
il y a même du foin marié pas marié
avoir avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas dans le projet là-bas
en tout cas aide pour l'accouchement
enfant immédiatement je les ai ici
les choses c'est, je pense que c'est
quatre-vingt-dix pour cent des avortements à la fois
frapper juste juste aime l'homme
vient dans les appartements a même oui et accouche
bébé et fois naturellement ce genre
faire des choses
souris très responsable
nous serons généralement de toutes les couleurs pour ainsi dire
couleurs nationales du Kirghizistan
ici c'est blanc et utada il y a une base de rouge et
le jaune est ce qui est dans les syllabes avant est connecté ici mais
Essayons de tout mettre ensemble
ici, c'est-à-dire que la finition sera comme ça
Emploi
ici on va faire aussi va comme ça
soulagement pour ainsi dire
parce qu'au-dessus, c'est-à-dire qu'il s'avérera que vous savez comment
comme si tout était installé dans ce bâtiment avec
la volonté rapide pense que la montagne
donc il y aura une image un tel soulagement
ce haut des ruches donnera un tel
image entre maintenant comment fier de lui
la couleur voici l'émission en rouge
voici un petit essai, la main va trembler, c'est tout
eh bien, elle ne nous touche pas
Oui, je me souviens de ce gratte-ciel fait en bas
nous sommes assis krutch en train de pleurer nous sommes assis en train de pleurer
comme si un boyger des nerfs d'un Letton
non, cela ne nous conviendra pas
comme ça en général
libérer
Il
oui comme les femmes
[musique]
tous ont déjà été commandés maintenant pour les parents
Dima et aujourd'hui les politiciens les accepteront avec leur esprit
et l'argent sera donné
en général, j'ai commencé à faire la même chose
probablement 6 ans de pâte à modeler est le premier
la réaction a été extrêmement négative en termes de
pour tirer partout avec un revolver
les groupes sur lesquels je suis c'était la première cuillère de ce genre
voler dans la pommade que partout la saleté de la pâte à modeler musa
Noël de tout ça
Qu'est-ce que leurs parents ont aimé en premier ?
avec qui j'étais assis j'étais un enfant calme
le petit était tranquillement foutu il était assis
c'est au moment où mes amis sont là mais
encore
arrête ça voulait papa
obtenir de l'aide jusqu'à présent si
J'avoue sincèrement que même cette cathédrale et
Je veux saluer pour la première fois de ma vie
a dit quelque chose alors je sais qu'il est tout
montrer maintenant à tous ses amis là-bas
et vend tous les amis savent déjà qu'ils ils
y reviennent déjà constamment des excursions à
J'ai autre chose là-bas, mais j'ai
ne dit jamais une telle retenue
homme fils c'est quelle beauté
bien sûr, vous êtes très linguistique pour vous ici
il y aura encore une aire de jeux, tout est encore là
finiront beaux ceux de quelque sorte
bravo merci dick talent titre
plafonds talan est la seule chose qui
ta mère était dans la famille de ma grand-mère
douze enfants ma mère elle-même est plus âgée
bébé et comment tout le monde serait méchant pour
Allemand comment c'était de marcher comme si on écrasait
reste comme si elle s'était levée
lui ainsi et ma mère a épousé un Russe et
donc elle ne pouvait pas parler à la famille
purement en allemand, beaucoup se sont réunis
invités sont venus parents où nous sommes
tout le monde est allé vers moi et il y a de l'argent
là ils ont des enfants mes cousins ​​et
Sœurs, elles ne connaissent pas bien le paradis
chaque fois que vous pensez que la vie peut être
pour toute la volonté de Dieu et comment puis-je mod
la vie peut aussi être vécue différemment
J'ai besoin de ça peut-être que je devrais
rester pour quelque chose ici son temps nous
ne pouvait pas partir, pour ainsi dire, aussi, tout en
l'allemagne en direct peut être sur le très pour
le fait que maintenant ici il peut être là
souhaite que ce soit Rome et tout cela ne serait pas
intéressé parce que maintenant
Qu'il vive le rêve et qu'il soit comme celui-là
faire de cette ville tout et chaque bâtiment
tout le monde sans même voir est très surpris
qu'en fait il n'était pas il n'était pas pour
la frontière n'était pas il n'a pas vu ça laissez moi
J'étais j'étais dans ces villes historiques
J'étais dans les temps anciens que j'ai moi-même vus et
affaires temporaires, je n'ai pas vu ce qu'il y avait et
regarde quelle sculpture de bégaiement qu'est-ce qu'il y a là
architecture tout ne suffirait jamais
brouillon de lien
à la sortie de la cassette vidéo du journal
Où elle est allée, je me souviens comment j'étais avec
regardé avec avidité tous ces bâtiments
qui étaient là
interdit cette vidéo particulière reproche à tous
ces palais et certains fauchés là-bas
l'architecture et souvenez-vous du gazouillis des oiseaux
ça me semblait en quelque sorte spécial là-bas
miné
en quelque sorte, cela me semblait spécial
un peu de romance donc à ce sujet dans ce
dans tout cela a donné quelque chose d'incitatif
on fait ça aussi
maintenant fortement semblé perdu 6
mois
juste bouge
diversité
regarder autour
je ne veux pas d'appareil dentaire
passé
[musique]
une série de coups que nous avons commencé le premier jour
satisfait de ce qui suit
[musique]
Aussi
c'est pourquoi je réfléchis à un projet
voici mon rêve d'enfant où ils veulent
visiter l'Allemagne dans ce style
fabriqué en allemand
L'Europe de l'Ouest fait attention à
drapeau rouge blanc jaune drapeau j'ai
couleur du sang rouge couleur blanche
la transparence de la gestion dans la diplomatie, puis
il y a un pays démocratique transparent
système racinaire et couleur couleur richesse or
la ville dorée de goldinburg elle-même
bouledogue compte maintenant
environ un demi-million d'habitants à la fin
quand il sera terminé, il sera
atteindre 720 mille habitants
c'est-à-dire que 2 versets de l'ordre seront ajoutés
deux cent vingt mille dans de nouvelles zones
c'est le centre-ville
les magasins les plus chers sont situés ici
bureaux des plus grandes entreprises
l'élite du logement cher ici est la plus élevée
gratte-ciel
est l'avenir avec tant de compagnie
gratte-ciel du trône national du poker
en plus, je suppose que j'ai fait du sang
le coût de l'hôtel est le quartier martin
ici se trouvent le plus
des boutiques chères or c'est aussi un hôtel
et bien sur le principal
attraction cathédrale arcs
réalisé en quatre styles d'architecture
cette plante
euh. puisqu'ici il produit des moteurs sur
le moteur lui-même, dans ce secteur pour
culture automobile à 42 à mon avis
capsules rappelez-vous alors capsules personnes dans
pods manèges si futuristes
la roue ferait cent trente trois mètres
hauteur
légèrement céder à l'oeil de londres à londres
celui-là fait 135 mètres de haut, me voilà un peu
l'a fait ressembler à Singapour
grande roue
là aussi, plus haut ce serait le troisième
altitude
alison review monde voici 72 mille
lieux
Maintenant
d'une idée telle que vous pouvez entendre qu'il y a quelque chose qui
J'ai dit que c'était ennuyeux là-bas
dans le chiffre d'affaires de Borisov.
mais mouvement
2 couteau et partager un camion de carburant qui est un hommage
[musique]
Oui
montrer en mots fait à l'intérieur
kurbatov n'aurait pas imprimé pour lui
Tanya regarde c'est un hommage et c'est
dinosaure
rends-le, ne le casse pas, cours comme ça
la queue de dinosaure fait un dinosaure
queue
Donc
Allons
[musique]
J'ai vu des trains à grande vitesse de bichkek de rêve,
vu sans elle ils mènent sur quelque chose
à un autre je ne sais pas quel genre d'énergie il y a
déplacé assez vite cependant
décalé pour être honnête et même rappelez-vous comment
l'homme est là
chinois en chine vue et bien qu'en chine mais
architecture il n'y avait pas de gratte-ciel
gratte-ciel et je n'ai rien vu
énormes bâtiments long kilomètre mari
peut-être même plus de métal, ce sont tous
très gazelles pas belles c'est sur mesure
disons choqué rien de tel
les grands vivent comme des zuev
il s'est avéré compact et toute accessibilité
les gens qui marchent m'ont trouvé très
aimé les membres d'une telle ville
complet, bien sûr, c'est ce que je suis, oui quoi
la ville sera une forêt complètement différente
vraiment donner aux gens alors comprendre que
immeuble de grande hauteur est très fort sur le psychisme
tout à fait il n'y a rien de tel que je n'ai pas vu
là pour appliquer l'expérience sur laquelle ils n'étaient pas
la zone était occupée, c'est-à-dire que le montant était
conçu
[musique]
UN
[applaudissements]
Natalia a commencé serait partie si en bonne santé
pas le même
attention, ma souris se casse
esicho le traîne pour que tu ne puisses pas vider sauvagement
a l'air cool et guide
ci-après, par la suite
je prends un gramme
là
c'est ce que je peux voir sur la chemise
la fin est le même baril silushka est irréaliste
dima bilan
maintenant important et plus
[musique]
Et
frire
[musique]
donc c'est notre foin, c'est juste
regarde comment ça tourne à paris
elle oui et juste ici sur ce
l'inversion c'est la tour parisienne
gustav eiffel regarde nous tous
copié en général après l'exposition us
il y avait déjà des colonies
Je suis assis ici depuis longtemps à venir moi-même
J'avais besoin d'un peu de dépression
commencé fort d'ailleurs tout est cool tout
l'appel n'a pas cassé le téléphone un tas de commandes
il était samedi
Dans la soirée
Au fait, j'étais assis là même moi-même, c'est pour moi
c'était quelque chose de fantastique
que mon père ne se contentera pas de regarder là-bas comme
s'enfuyait habituellement qu'il s'asseyait avec moi
nous avons parlé avec lui les gens sont entrés
a même expliqué les photos là-bas en fonction de ce qu'il a montré
bien, pour moi c'est quelque chose
fantastique exposition générale dire
jusqu'à 100 je m'y attendais
la seule composition du sol que j'ai fortement
se fatiguer
Avec
Je suis venu ici l'endroit est à proximité
il y en a une grosse pierre qui se balance à côté
J'y ai fait des maisons, je me souviens de cette ville
disposé un tas de photos mettre 20 dedans
presque 23 ans j'ai aménagé quelque part pour goûter
3 et je vais y déposer quelque chose de chaud
photo et faire des bâtiments là-bas
les gens de cul de burg se souviennent de moi oh oui
il y avait plus de sept mille
mec, oui, j'ai déjà commencé à lire ici et
Je me souviens du bonheur des soldats
D'une manière ou d'une autre, ils sont arrivés et se sont assis l'un à côté de l'autre et ont regardé
qu'avant les gens se demandaient
ils peuvent ne pas être là pour longtemps et bien sûr
assis sur de toute façon ne me dérangeait pas
Au moment où je me suis levé avec le travail, je me suis enfui
avait tellement hâte de dîner
cette ville et si les parents
Au moment où ils me connaîtraient, non, ils auraient
bien sur le premier
[musique]